nos encontramos en el mercado de barbas
yobo el mercado más grande de la ciudad
de jarquín la segunda ciudad más grande
de ucrania con un millón 400 mil
habitantes este mercado fue atacado
entre los días 16 y 17 de marzo y como
pueden ver quedaron prácticamente todos
los locales calcinados en una de las
mayores explosiones que hubo en una
ciudad que ha sido tal vez la más
atacada desde el comienzo de la guerra
según han anunciado las autoridades en
los últimos días dicen que desde el 24
de febrero cuando comenzó la invasión
más de 978 personas civiles han muerto
en la ciudad 48 de ellas niños y 5.000
edificios habitados por civiles han sido
alcanzados por misiles por cohetes y por
bombas racimo según han investigado
organizaciones no gubernamentales como
amnistía internacional
según las naciones unidas en toda
ucrania desde el comienzo de la guerra
más de 5000 personas han muerto sin
embargo estos lo que ellos han podido
confirmar ha incluido también aquí en la
ciudad de heart kit donde hay un
elemento interesante como podemos ver
atrás hay varios comercios abiertos en
este momento está lloviendo y personas
que estaban alrededor han buscado
refugio pero esto es una tendencia que
hemos visto en la ciudad la resistencia
de los ucranianos también se extiende a
seguir su vida cuando se calman las
bombas cuando llega la tranquilidad
vuelven a abrir sus comercios y se tiran
a la calle y esta ciudad todavía no está
totalmente
en paz hace pocos días caían varias
explosiones seis personas morían entre
ellos un niño con su padre y las bombas
siguen cayendo con frecuencia no tanto
como al principio pero siguen siendo
atacada la población y ellos siguen
resistiendo y saliendo a la calle